good evening and welcome aboard I don't
doubt it
welcome to Jabberwocky bookshop I'm
Events Director Kelly Horan Jones and
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
here for an evening with how weak our
celebrated columnist radio talk show
host journalist and author Howie Carr
has built his career on courage he asks
the tough questions and he demands
straight answers he's also the father of
five daughters so I think we know where
he gets his practice with the brothers
Belcher Howie Carr has given us a
stunning expose and a riveting a true
crime tale of how corruption wound its
way up from Boston's seedy criminal
underbelly to the city's elite ranks
courtesy of a pair of notorious siblings
working both ends of the spectrum please
join me in welcoming an author that the
mob might rather were swimming with the
fishes but we're so glad he's here with
us tonight ladies and gentlemen Howie
Carr
[Applause]
thanks a lot everybody
we have c-span here tonight so I got to
keep this sign up very glad to be here
I'll be I got a lot of magnets here for
everybody because I'll be passing out
I'll sign anything you've got except a
basketball for those of you who aren't
familiar with the story there's say
there's a guy out it's gonna be on 60
minutes tomorrow night he says that they
were they were going to kill me at the
as I came out of my house in in Acton
and the first they were going to what
they said they were gonna put a
basketball full of c-4 plastic
explosives you know Dynamite's not good
enough for him you know that's just
that's just too commonplace it's too
easy to get we'll get some of that James
Bond stuff and that's what why do you
want it to do and you know a basketball
I I don't know what that's all about is
most of you who listen to my radio show
and though they would had a better
chance of getting me to pick up
something if it they put some c4 and I
don't know some donuts or some fried
clams or something a basketball anything
we're gonna then we're going to pick me
off from the this graveyard across the
street and you know I just haven't been
taken it very seriously I talked to a PR
guy today who's a friend of mine and he
said you know how he may be you know you
should have been less dismissive you
know you know saying he didn't have the
stones to shoot me you know that makes
you seem like you're a street guy too
you know
why didn't you you know talk about the
First Amendment then you know how what a
courageous journalist you were at all
that but the thing is I've been hearing
this guy tell this story for for 10
years now you know
his a close personal relative of his
lives around the corner from where I
lived it's not like they had to do any
investigating they knew where they you
know the guy probably his relative
probably just pointed out the house and
said that's where how he lives and it
slowly began you know the way it is with
you know you go to
high school or college was somebody they
barely make the football team or the
basketball team and they're their scrubs
Benchwarmers five years later you run
into him at a party and they're talking
about how they started right ten years
later they were all conference it's the
same thing this guy was the gravedigger
and now he's promoted himself up to
being a hit man so I wrote that at my
column on Thursday afternoon you know
that he was promoting himself from
gravedigger to hitman I go home and I'm
looking on the internet to see how the
story's playing on the on the wires and
it says hitman hired to kill columnist I
said it worked you know in the military
they give you battlefield promotions
this guy gave himself a graveyard
promotion but I'm glad to be here
tonight and to talk about the the
Bulger's and you know we we all know who
they are they're these two brothers
there's Whitey Jimmy Bulger the the the
hoodlum the cocaine dealer the serial
killer and then there's his his brother
the president of the Massachusetts state
Senate at one time the president of the
University of Massachusetts also known
as the corrupt [ __ ] people say Howie
did you invent that name I say no was
invented by a judge whose court he
basically destroyed he invented the name
but I picked it up and ran with it
the CM and you know the the thing is I'm
gonna I want to just throw it open to
questions mostly but I'll just do the
the quick chronology here of the two
brothers the whitey bulger was a career
criminal there's there's a good story I
think in my book about his one of his
early adventures in crime he was he
Billy Bulger the future president of the
Senate and will McDonough you remember
him he was the Boston Globe sports
columnist in the NFL analyst will
McDonough was a also from South Boston
and so they they're they're about 12
years old ice or so something like that
12 13 years old they're coming back from
the beach on a on a summer day and all
of a sudden whitey pulls up in a
Cadillac convertible Cadillac he's
wearing no shirt they've never seen the
Cadillac before and so what he says get
in and even then they knew better than
to refuse an invitation he was making
him an offer they couldn't refuse so
Billy and will and you jump into the
Cadillac and they don't know where it's
coming from and white he's just driving
along you know shirtless just kind of
whistling and enjoying the sights and
then they come to one of those old
there's this kid pedaling one of those
old ice-cream trucks
you know the freezer is built onto the
onto the bike and and I guess Billy
Billy leans forward and says to whitey
that's O'Leary I never liked that kid
O'Leary and white he goes really so he
pulls the car in right behind the bike
and he taps the bike and the kid of
course immediately freaks out goes crazy
and starts pedaling furiously trying to
get away and whitey laughs pulls the car
up again closer to him the Cadillac taps
the kid again and he's just now he's
really out of control because he thinks
he's about to be run over by the big car
so he's going faster and faster and so
Billy leans forward and says Jimmy I
said I didn't like him I didn't tell you
to kill him and white he laughed and
said I'm not gonna kill him
the bus is gonna kill him when he goes
through Broadway without stopping so
even even at an early age why do you
like to have other people do his dirty
work for him and I think he he was the
he was the guy after he wasn't released
from prison until 1965 as you know if
you've read the book he took part in the
LSD experiments in Atlanta the response
at the Atlanta penitentiary that were
sponsored by the CIA and he wrote a lot
about that I put a lot of the the the
writings that he did in his in his final
months in Boston he was I think he was
trying to set himself up as some kind of
victim as you know as a government
program run amok kind of like a white
Tuskegee project you know and so he
blamed that for his problems then then
he got transferred to Alcatraz and he
was spent three years there met one of
the loves of his life and I named the
Choctaw kid whose funeral he later paid
for when he died of AIDS and then he
went to Leavenworth and then he got out
in 1965 when he got out in 65 his
brother Billy was just a freshman stay
rep and it was not a freshman I think
it's a second term a second a third term
but he was a backbencher and but as soon
as as soon as whitey was out on the
street and he was at the lowest rungs of
organized crime at the time he was just
a muscle guy for for some fading top dog
in Southie and Billy's just the
back-bencher but they immediately began
rising to the top and it all had to do
with the FBI the the FBI the federal
government promoted them and how many
people here remember John J McCormack
yeah I do too were the old-timers in the
audience the kids are going home he was
the Speaker of the US House of
Representatives he was from South Boston
and after JFK was shot in 1963 he was
one heartbeat away from the presidency
if anything if LBJ had had a heart
attack he would have become President of
the United States and this was a guy who
took care of the Bulger's the Bulger's
were his constituents again you go back
in the early part of my book I got the
documents about the
from Whitey's uh military career and I
know this will surprise a lot of you but
whitey was a disciplinary problem in the
Air Force and they were they were they
were having disciplinary hearings it was
one step below a court-martial and so I
got the I got the actual not the
transcripts but the description of the
the hearing and at one point he says he
says you better not do anything to me or
I'll call my congressman John McCormack
and so that's Israel that's 1952 they're
there
and of course John McCormack had a
brother named knock oh great name right
knock though McCormack what how Southie
is it knock Oh was the biggest bookie in
town
he had a big bar in Andrew square and
every st. Patrick's they can ride the
ride his horse had to be a big horse to
like a Clydesdale because he weighed
about 400 pounds hit ride it through
there anyway McCormack in 1968 he does
another favor for the Bulger family that
one of their neighbors a guy named John
Connolly John zip Connolly wants to get
on the FBI and you know who writes that
first letter to get zip Connolly on to
the FBI who wrote the letter to J Edgar
Hoover John McCormack to Speaker of the
House and for those of you who aren't
familiar with where zip is now this is
my magnet this is him in an orange in an
orange jumpsuit he'll be standing trial
in Florida next month on first-degree
murder charges involving one of the
gangland hits now once they get once
they get the Connolly into the FBI and
then they got him back to Boston and
he's just taken care of business with
with the Bulger's pretty soon he's taken
he's taken money from from whitey and oh
by the way another thing is another
favor that the FBI does for whitey 1971
again he's not he hasn't moved that far
up in the ranks of the organized crime
but all of a sudden J Edgar Hoover of
all people J Edgar Hoover sends
of memo to the Boston office of the FBI
ordering them to recruit whitey as an
informant again it was probably a favor
from a Cormac because McCormick even
though he hadn't retired as Speaker by
then he probably knew that the this was
what was this this was the way to
protect whitey so anyway they I can run
over the rest of the story pretty pretty
quickly you know what happened at this
point
whitey wipes out his competition in
South Boston joins the Winter Hill Gang
from Somerville they get involved in in
race fixing everybody's about to be
indicted and all of a sudden at the last
minute thanks to the intervention of zip
Connolly and another couple of FBI
agents and some US and some people in
the US Attorney's Office whitey and his
partner Steve Flemmi are cut out of the
indictment so that basically all of
their colleagues in the so-called Irish
mafia although it's Irish in Italian
both are taken off the board next Billy
Bulger he's he his path to the Senate
presidency is blocked by two guys one of
whom is from this area Kevin Harrington
is from Salem is the Salem this area
considered this area yeah right yeah and
the other guy is uh Joe DeCarlo who was
a the same age as him another guy from
Suffolk County Revere and what happens
not that not that these guys were
particularly innocent but the FBI after
a very fitful investigation sends a zip
Connolly out to get the info they indict
Joe DeCarlo he's convicted he files an
appeal that brings down Harrington and
all of a sudden Billy Bulger is the
president of the Senate and guess what
the two the two lawyers the two lawyers
for the for the two senators the Carlo
and the Republican bagman McKenzie they
didn't do a very good job how are they
rewarded judgeships there's someone
who's read read the book right right
yeah you remember yeah yeah I talked to
the I talked to meant that the Joe
DeCarlo didn't want to talk to me when I
was doing the book but I talked to some
of his friends and family members and
they said they thought of doing their
own book and the only they'd only gotten
as far as a tie
you know what the title was it's worse
than you think I said that's a good
title now you gotta get to work on the
rest of the block so then then at this
point Billy is the president of the
Senate and but why he still has to worry
about the Mafia so what do they do
paging zip Connolly paging zip Connolly
let's take the Mafia off the board for
the for the Bulger's so they they they
put they put whitey in as a as one of
the informants for the search warrant if
you're on that title three it's called
you're not going to be prosecuted even
though you know your name turns up in
criminal wrongdoing on the wiretap
because it would open the open the
grounds to an appeal so whitey whitey
has the mafia taken off the board and
all of a sudden he's on top of the whole
the whole rackets world in Boston and at
this point Billy's on top and politics
Whitey's on top in the organized crime
and suddenly people who cross whitey who
work in state government start to suffer
consequences serious consequences there
was a lieutenant colonel of the State
Police Jaco Donovan he put a bug in a
garage on Lancaster Street in the West
End of Boston where whitey was hanging
out why he didn't care for that the next
budget and an anonymous outside writer
is attached to the Senate budget that
would have forced the requirement of
Lieutenant Colonel Jack O'Donovan and
you know who vetoed it Edie King gets
such a bad rap as the when he was the
governor but he was the LAT until Mitt
Romney he was the last governor to tell
tell Billy Bulger no you know the story
of the state trooper I think he's a guy
from Essex Essex counties and he's
deceased now Billy Johnson he was a
state trooper at Logan Airport you know
that's the that's the plush assignment F
Troop and
he was at the International Terminal one
day and whitey comes through with a bag
of cash he's taking it to Montreal
he was even then he was planning his
escape his flight and trooper Johnson
stops him from going through when the
when the cash shows up on the on at the
security gate in the x-ray and he and he
and whitey are going at it and white he
gets rid of the cash and the next day
mike dukakis governor dukakis's nominee
for the guy who runs Logan Airport forms
show the shows up at the barracks at
Logan Airport and demands the police
report Billy Johnson refuses to give it
to him he's out he sent to a less
desirable location he had a he had a guy
named Johnny powers the former Senate
President from South Boston I'm not
gonna ask anybody to raise their hands
if they remember Johnny powers see it
the dog track he's been gone a long time
but he ran the courthouse patronage
operation the courthouse payroll whitey
had a no-show job at the courthouse
there questions who got him the job
whether was will McDonough or Billy
Bulger will McDonough claimed the credit
for it
Johnny powers finally said I can't have
this guy on the payroll even if it's a
no-show job these guys have the keys to
the district attorney's office so he
fired whitey after Billy became the
Senate President what happened to Johnny
powers his pay was frozen for five years
his aides pay was frozen for five years
and of course Billy denied that he had
anything to do with this the he he
couldn't remember anything about it the
only way he ever found out about it was
he read about it in the newspapers even
they give you another example before I
throw it open to questions I the mask
Convention Center Authority people
people really seems to be surprised when
I talk about the mask Convention Center
Authority even though I've written
written about it for four years it seems
like the mask Convention Center
Authority was set up basically to
originally to to enable Boston to to get
some money to settle some abatement
lawsuits and that kind of stuff and deal
with prop two-and-a-half and there's the
state
got this new quasi public authority as
it's called in a built the Heinz
Convention Center on Boylston Street
that was a great investment by the way
after they paid off the bonds they spent
four hundred and fifty million dollars
on the Heinz Convention Center Authority
the new treasurer at Tim Cahill ordered
an assessment of it when he got into
office remember four hundred and fifty
million it was spent you know what it's
worth thirty five million
well that's taking advantage of the real
estate boom in Massachusetts uh so the
first guy that gets hired is as the
executive director of the mass
Convention Center Authority is Francis
Xavier Joyce what's his claim to fame
he's the ten whistle player in Billy
Baltar's Band the Irish Volunteers he
becomes the the he becomes the chairman
the executive director a lifetime
appointment one of his first hires a
woman named Nancy Stanley who was Nancy
Stanley's mother Teresa Stanley Whitey's
girlfriend another one of the early
appointments
Lisa Montano does that name ring a bell
her father is Johnny Martorano the hit
man for whitey she immediately gets
bagged for embezzling of twenty one
thousand dollars and they send in her
her uncle Jimmy Montano to negotiate the
settlement with a with a former FBI
agent who's a friend another friend of
the Bulger family named Bob Sheehan Bob
Sheehan is the FBI agent who offered
another gangster name to Scheels who
whitey had shot at one point but I
digress
shion offers Sheils the gangster the
keys to the angiulos mafia headquarters
in the north end and a machine gun to
take him out and for his fine
performance in the pursuit of law and
order
Sheehan gets a job at the MCC a and he
settles up the Montano thing they got it
they own the under common garage the new
mask Convention Center Authority who's
one of the first people that gets hired
or gets kept on there guy named Eddie
Goss
Eddie Goss happens to be one of the
original criminal partners of Stevie
Fleming who was Whitey's underworld
partner he too went to the can by the
way for stealing money submit me you
hire people from organized crime and
they steal money go figure
so this is what's been this is what has
been going on for a long time and you
know people people say well how'd they
get away with it how come nobody wrote
about this for all these years and this
gets back to the the headlines in the
last few days involving me then when
there was a guy named Paul Corsetti
worked for the Boston Herald and he was
a he was a tough guy he was from Medford
he was a second-generation police
reporter and he was a Vietnam vet drove
a truck over there not no shrinking
violet he was working on a story once
1980 about a murder white he had killed
a guy named Louis litt off' who was
doing freelance hits so he had to go so
they he went and they they dumped him
off over in the south end there all
areas and he knows laundromat I don't
know if it was a message to the Mafia or
what or just they that was just a nice
place to drop him but anyway course
seven he starts working on the story and
he gets a call for it from some guy who
gives him some tantalizing hints and
says you want to find out some more
about the letter fit meet me down in
Quincy Market in one of the bars so Paul
says okay I'll go down there so he goes
down there and he's he's sitting on the
barstool waiting for this whoever to
show up he doesn't know the guy's name
so this uh you know this average-sized
middle-aged guy he sidles up next to him
in the school and says hey aren't you
Paul course and he starts making small
talk with him Paul plays along for a
while and then he finally says I you
know I'd like to keep talking to you but
I'm
for somebody the guy looks at him it
says you're waiting for me mother bleep
er I'm Jimmy Bulger and I kill people
and the pulse pulls out of his coat a
sheet of paper and he reads the home
address of Paul Corsetti the the make
and model of his car his wife's car the
license plates and then he then he says
and here's where your daughter goes to
the daycare center and he shows a
picture of the daughter next day I still
remember it like it was yesterday
because I was working at the Herald at
the time Paul Corsetti shows up in the
city room wearing a gun and he goes to
the Boston Police and they say there's
nothing we can do we got him for we got
him for 50 murders so he goes he goes to
Larry Bayonne II the number-two guy in
the Mafia and and he sits down with him
and Larry says what can I do for you and
he says says I got a problem with this
guy Whitey Bulger and Larry goes ah I
could help you with anybody else but
that whitey he's crazy no kidneys crazy
well they finally they finally got it
straightened out but for five years
after that nobody wrote anything about
it there's a there's a there's a quote I
use in my book I actually have it on
videotape Chris Lydon got it in 1979
from Kevin white it was the mayor of
Boston and Kevin white was dude they
were doing the cutaways so sort of semi
off-the-record
but what Kevin said Chris Lydon who said
you know the media won't go after the
tough ones like Billy and he said you
know he said if my brother threatened to
kill you or you thought he would you'd
be nothing but nice to me this the mayor
of Boston saying this and then he said
the one time during busing he was over
in South Boston at the Athletic Club
and he was afraid to come out at night
because he thought whitey was going to
kill him and as he said he
because whitey was crazy enough even
then and he said if they you know if
they knocked me out they're gonna get an
anti busing guy named Jerry O'Leary who
later went to the can that's a recurring
theme in this book people going to the
can
and I don't mean the men's room either
and that's that was again that was a
large degree to a large degree the
source of their power
he he he took whitey was was mister
mister Menace he was the shadow behind
the throne and you know I've told the
story a million times now but the Jack
Hynes
who I worked with at channel 56 the son
the former Channel five anchor the yes
the son of the former mayor of Boston
they had this liquor store that they
extorted the knife written about that in
the book as well four brothers Bulger
and the the liquor store was halfway
between the Herald where I work in
channel 56 where I used to work you know
the globe halfway between The Herald and
the globe so I go by it every day or
just about every day why do you used to
hang out there it was the damnedest
thing you ever saw you know he'd be
standing out there he liked to do
business there's a rotary right at the
liquor store and it was a good place to
you know do bad things sneaky stuff
because they it didn't matter what kind
of bug they put on the the noise is too
much from the cars so they'd be hanging
out there and that see me going by
so guess what I meant
didn't matter if I if I had a thirst so
great it would cast the shadow I wasn't
going in that liquor store I was cutting
across the injury square so they figured
it out that I was never going in the
liquor store so they asked Jack Hynes
one night he goes Anna nice and they say
yeah how come how he never comes in here
Jack Jack kind of backs away they say
will you tell Howie if he ever comes in
here
we got a dumpster waiting for him out
back it'll be another Robin Benedict and
she of course was the combat zone
prostitute who got chopped up and they
never found any parts of her body after
that I started driving home a different
way every night you know I never never
had never hung out as much as JJ Foley's
anymore either didn't want to get caught
flat-footed coming out of there one
night around midnight with two or three
beers in me but then later on they they
decided the whitee way was really
paranoid about about the press they they
also one point whitey one of Whitey's
minions was recorded to say boy is
Whitey mad at Howie now the other guy
says what did he do now and he says well
you see the thing in Boston Magazine
where they said whitey was worth 50
million dollars how we wrote that whitey
says how he set in himself setting him
up for a snatch by the Italians he
talked about paranoia but they also
delayed it to other reporters as well
you know there was a guy at the globe
who was a who used to work at the Herald
guy named Kevin Colin and he was working
on the the story in 1988 about the the
connections between the two brothers and
they were the the FBI at this point was
concerned that they were going to be
embarrassed
for obvious reasons because there was so
much to embarrass them with and so they
sent a guy out to talk to they sent a
guy had to call Colin who was one of the
reporters and they said I just talked to
I just talked to this guy and he
mentioned the name of one of the one of
the people who was in the race fixing
scandal from ten years earlier and he
says this guy wanted me to tell you that
watch out what you do with whitey cuz
he's gonna clip you if you do anything
and of course that was a beautiful
beautiful sort of misdirection play
because the guys in the witness
protection
program how do you go how do you confirm
it you can't confirm it you just have to
take the FBI agents word for it they
tried they did they cook they made the
one call and then they never called him
again 1988 of course who was also the
year that the the George Bush was
running for president against Mike
Dukakis and and even though Mike Dukakis
gave Billy Bulger everything he wanted
as president of the state Senate he
still didn't like Mike Dukakis going
back to the days of busing and he like
George Bush because George Bush always
called into the st. Patrick's Day
breakfast and came up with some good
jokes and all that sort of thing and so
19 July 1988 the Democratic convention
in Atlanta ends remember it Dukakis was
ahead by 17 points I don't know about
you I was pretty scared but Billy Bulger
according to members of the Bush family
called the Vice President George HW Bush
and said I think you want to come up to
Boston and have a photo-op
on Boston Harbor because you know
governor Dukakis is always talking about
how competent he is and what a great
environmentalist he is but the harbors
filthy a federal judge had to order the
cleanup it's costing billions of dollars
you could really dust him up with it and
George Bush came to the harbor had a
great press conference pretty soon
dukakis's lead was evaporate had
evaporated and since then Bush 41 has
supposedly told people that that's what
turned the campaign around and I still I
still don't think Dukakis even those he
must be the last guy in Massachusetts
not to know what what happened to him
because whenever whenever they try to
take away Billy Baltar's pension he's
always the guy who writes the op-ed
piece in The Boston Globe maybe I should
send him a copy of the book it's the
only way I'll ever read it I know he's
not gonna pay for it
but one thing about that billy is I know
that he has great ties to the to the to
the Bush Republicans in addition of
course to being a nominal Democrat and
we can see that from the 2000
presidential debates we all know that
the most important debate is the first
one right because that's the one
everybody's watching where was the first
presidential debate held in in the year
2000 it was held at UMass Boston when he
was the president of UMass he obviously
had to tie in to the Bush family and he
had to tie in to the Democrats through
Ted Kennedy who he was even then
negotiating with I supposed to get the
to get Ted Kennedy's papers whatever
that means for the UMass library but of
course the the bloom was a little off
the Rose you know that was it was
Billy's last great victory I guess as a
politician as president of UMass
but the balloon was a little off the
rose when the National reporters when
they looked out of the debate hall out
onto the harbor they would see on on the
beach state police backhoes and they
were digging up the death pits where
were whitey had left all of his victims
and I mean that that's just sort of the
whole story encapsulated right there you
know just you know you have the highest
supposedly the highest and then the the
absolute lowest pits of the underworld
and it's this it's the same family and
it's it's within a hundred yards of one
another but anyway I know there are a
lot of books to sign here and a lot of
people have a lot of questions so I'll
just I'll be glad to take some questions
it's really nice I appreciate that
Jabberwocky for having me here tonight
and and it's great it's great to be in
Newburyport even though I call the names
Barry and I
I know I've got to work I've got to work
on my Essex County geography I
understand that and when we go into the
trade paperback I'm gonna make Salisbury
New Hampshire Salisbury Massachusetts as
a chip bait I'm very embarrassed by that
little error okay any questions yes sir
yes why he didn't have me knocked off
yeah no I think again if if I had made a
mistake in in South Boston if I had been
in the wrong place at the wrong time and
it had been night and no one had been
around if I if I just stumbled into the
into the liquor store you know totally
loaded I mean they might have put me in
the dumpster but I wasn't gonna I just
wasn't gonna make that mistake and and
they had they've gotten so used to
having their own way threatening guys
like they got away with threatening
Corsetti they got away with threatening
Colin they basically got away with
threatening me you know and again any of
us who are we gonna call we gonna call
the FBI he was he was paying off six
guys in the FBI zip Connolly didn't even
cash his paychecks for months at a time
he was getting so much cash was it who
was I gonna call the Boston Police
Department what was the first thing when
ray Flynn became mayor in 1984
succeeding Kevin White who was afraid
what was that what was the first favor
that Billy Bulger asked of ray Flynn his
neighbor from South Boston he wanted him
to a point
zip Connolly as the police commissioner
of the city of Boston he wanted they
wanted to put a gangster I mean a flood
that's not some you know guy who's an
associate but I mean basically a made
member of the crew in as the as the
police chief of the city of Boston so
they want to control the FBI and the
Boston Police Department when I heard
ray said no I've always had a higher
respect for Ray since then yes yes sir
well well again you know I've been there
from the beginning on it with the Kevin
weeks threats like I said his he has a
close relative and I'm not gonna I don't
even want to name the relative because
I'm not gonna I won't throw him under
the bus Kevin apparently doesn't care
about throwing his own relative under
the bus but he lived around the corner
from me that's that's how he knew where
I lived they didn't need to do any
sleuthing to find out where I lived I
mean the guy would just tell him and
Kevin Kevin weeks he has gone into court
over and over again as a defendant and
as a witness against guys like zip
Connolly and and said that he had
nothing to do with the murders he said
at one point they asked him why didn't
you try to stop some of these murders
and he said because if I try if I say
anything I'm going into the hole next to
the other person and now so now now that
he's not under oath he's saying he's
doing he's doing these he's gonna do a
hit on me he's gonna whack me out so
when is he lying is he lying under oath
or is he lying in the book it's got it's
got to be one of the other he can't he
can't have it both ways and the and the
silly stuff I mean the basketball come
the exploding basketball come on Death
Wish 5 anyone there was a Three Stooges
in 1938 they pretended to be professors
and they got a and then the professor's
were chasing him they got an exploding
basketball and give you another one the
replacement Keller's anyone ever see the
replacement killers it's a crappy movie
too like all the other movies he
apparently watches but in the the this
killer is gonna shoot city he's gonna
shoot a cop coming out of his house and
he sees that the the the cop has his son
with him and the Sun has been actually
bouncing a basketball so it's like Kevin
may have seen that one and then split
the story into I don't know I just again
believe me when I felt whitey was after
me I was petrified I was extremely
concerned I I I took all kinds of
precautions but but this guy is I don't
know if it's gonna make 60 minutes but I
said this guy is is Robin - uh -
Whitey's Batman
he's uh he's nothing to fear yes I I
think white he is in the United Kingdom
yeah he has I'm pretty sure he hasn't
been in the United States since 1996
they the FBI he is he fled in December
of 1994 and finally in mid-1996 after
giving him a nice
I don't know 18-month headstart the FBI
decided to interview his former
girlfriend to find out what his alias
was I mean that's when they that's when
they should have gotten him was back in
1995 or 1996 actually the cop stalked
him local cops in Mississippi and I
believe Wyoming stopped him for traffic
violations when he was what he was
Thomas Baxter
but since the FBI had never bothered to
find out that that was his alias they
didn't know they just let him go
and so yeah yes sir Bradley do such a
puff piece on Billy Bulger now you're on
TV within tomorrow night you must have
got to talk to him about that while you
were doing your well hurry did you but
he treated it like god this guy wasn't
one of the worst criminals in states
actually I gotta stay I gotta stand up
for Ed Bradley and that was Morley Safer
who did that puff piece on Billy Bulger
and Bradley did the piece on Eddie
McKenzie the guy who claimed there was a
dog the dog room which there were there
were questions about that by the way ed
Bradley you know in his youth he went to
prep school with with Johnny Montano for
a year down in Rhode Island and I Ed
Bradley was an offensive lineman and
Johnny Martorano was the was the
fullback and Ed Bradley told me they
named for ruff for Johnny they call them
the milkman because he always delivered
a few years later he was delivering
something other than milk but I you know
the thing was it's it's good for it's
good for my book to be on with with that
Bradley on 60 minutes I you know I I
would prefer not to give credence to
what the weeks but you know what the
hell I'll go along it's good for
business and you know and the other
thing about it the other thing about Ed
Bradley is he has the he has sort of the
proper perspective on this he when we
were doing the cutaways during the
during the shooting at the four seasons
he said you know he said we're moving
our way up the mob totem pole so we
started at the bottom with Eddie
McKenzie we've moved a smidgen up with
Kevin weeks said next stop Johnny
Martorano yes yeah Joe Moakley was
pretty big in Southie hundy escaped
Oakley Joe Moakley was one of their
neighbors you know he was he was another
guy who came out of the the Old Colony
housing projects and he gave Joe Billy
always followed in Joe Meaux Cleese
footsteps Joe Moakley gave up his his
seat in the House of Representatives in
1960 Billy Billy took the took the seat
1970 Joe gives up his seat in the Senate
to run again to run for McCormack seat
when he when he run doesn't run and
Billy succeeds him they were there were
always buddies you know I remember at
the when when Moakley died the longtime
congressman from South Boston who was
succeeded by Steve Ledge Billy gave this
tearful interview on TV and said said
you know and the worst of the times you
know meaning when they were digging up
the death pits and the worst of the
times Joe sat down with me to show that
he wasn't deserting the family so they
were they were buddies but I mean he
wasn't he wasn't
you wanna read sir or a variety store at
Southie you had the ball just collect
them at every store there yeah yeah yeah
well I mean yeah then will you stay you
know you know how tough there if you've
got if anybody's got a got a liquor
license or no or his work than a liquor
store you know how tough the state is on
you know they really they really enforce
the rules fairly fairly strictly but
when when they own that liquor store
they were selling to all the bars in the
in the town in South Boston right out of
a liquor store I mean that's just a
total violation of the law yes sir how a
great book would you comment dip
Connelly such a corrupt FBI agent
amorous and on and on in the book would
you comment on how many people are
falsely imprisoned in the Boston area
and probably throughout the country it
just seems like the the FBI is the
political police department for the
politicians and is there a possible
follow a book about that well I don't I
don't know what I'm gonna do for a
follow-up book but you're right you're
right about the FBI the the the amazing
thing about the Boston FBI office is
that there there have been two got two
agents indicted for on first-degree
murder charges in in states as far away
as Oklahoma in Florida
gangland hits no the FBI I've talked to
people in New York I've been on New York
radio talk shows and I say have two
agents in New York ever been indicted
for the four gangland hits and they know
the answer is no the the you know the
worst one of the bunch maybe even worse
than Connolly was this guy H Paul Rico
Rico was a was was the guy who who was
first to first met whitey in when whitey
was a male hustler in the in the Bay
Village in the early 1950s and he was J
Edgar Hoover put Rico in charge of
bringing down the Mafia and J Edgar
Hoover put out this memo in 1961 and
said he was under heat taking a lot of
pressure from Robert Kennedy the new
Attorney General to crack down on La
Cosa Nostra and he sent out a memo and
he said we're gonna use the same
techniques we used against the American
Communist Party against the Mafia which
of course we know what that
means anything goes you know forget you
know forget the Bill of Rights forget
anyone's constitutional protections just
go after him and get him and that's
really what led to all the abuse and
then Rico Rico ended up he had two guys
hit because they crossed him in the in
the Irish gang wars of the 60s then he
was the one who ordered the the hit on
Roger wheeler the guy who owned world
highway in 1982 the ironic thing is I'll
take some more questions here I always
loved this part of the book and I you
know what he got cut out he got left on
the cutting room floor when I was I I
feel I'm gonna put it back in if I get
it to write a new edition Rico orders
he's killed he's he's ordered at least
three possibly four or five hits right
he's a retired FBI agent he's running
this high light company remember alcee
hastings the he's now a congressman from
florida he was a corrupt federal judge
he was taken he was taking payoffs they
said we want to bring down Alcee
Hastings we need some FBI agent who can
pretend to be a Mafia don convincingly
paging H Paul Rico so after the guy just
months after the guy has been ordering
organized crime hits he has to pretend
to be a dawn who organizes who orders
organized crime heads any and he brought
down all CLC Hastings but again so he
went from being on the federal bench to
being in the US Congress yes sir
how did Rico last as long as he did I
mean you know I don't know about the
Mafia but the FBI had a real good
America system going you know it was
enforced it was enforced into the into
about 2001 I got all the memos from the
from the the hearings you know when they
had the the the the pre-trial hearings
in 1997-1998 about these guys being FBI
informants whitey was an FBI informant
quote-unquote but he they were basically
giving giving him information and return
for money and the the amazing thing
about the hit that actually led to the
hearings in Washington that brought down
Billy Bulger that was the Teddy Deegan
hit in 1965 the FBI knew two days
Riko wrote a memo to jr. Hoover two days
before Teddy Deegan was killed saying
they're doing they're doing dry runs on
the hit and he named everybody who was
gonna kill him
the morning after the hit Rico wrote
another memo to Washington saying who
had done the murder and yet three years
later Rico that his one of his top
informants 'got the first guy in the
witness protection program Joao Barbosa
lie under oath and send four innocent
men to prison for 30 years just to
protect his informant and that's that
quote I plan the the sound cut I play on
the radio show all the time when Chris
Shay's the Connecticut congressman says
says to him how do you feel
you framed four innocent men you stood
by and let them go too pretty first you
should have prevented the murder because
you knew it was going to take place and
then after the murder you you you let
these guys do 30 years and of course H
Paul Rico's response is yeah what do you
want for tears
yes sir yeah there were a lot of fellow
travelers in the media at the time and
and one of the worst I think was Mike
Barnicle who whose career ended in
disgrace as you know and at the Boston
Globe and he after after whitey rate one
the both the mass millions in Southie he
said that the the only that he'd be
giving the money to what the bums on the
street in South Boston and that the only
the only conversation whitey and Billy
had was past the gravy
on Sunday afternoons at the at their
house and then when when Johnny monarch
Johnny Martorano when he finally flipped
he knew a lot about Conley's crimes and
so as soon as as soon as it became clear
that Johnny Martorano was going to be a
real threat to zip Connolly's freedom
Barnacle wrote a column it turned out to
be the last column he ever wrote for the
globe and it was just the it was just
the most atrocious nonsense he ever
wrote in an in a in a 25 year career of
writing atrocious nonsense he said he
said that Johnny Martorano used to use
blacks for target practice in Roxbury he
said he said he killed three black women
in in one fell swoop in 1969 he killed
he killed one I mean I'm not making
excuses for Johnny Martorano he was a
serial killer too but this this guy
Barnacle just made up the whole thing to
try to protect a billion whitey it was
it was disgraceful there were there were
other people at the globe who were who
were just as bad but let's not forget
the globe also was was the the first
newspaper to actually try to point out
the connection that whitey would be an
FBI informant so you know I can't I
can't totally knock the globe but I can
sure knock Mike Barnicle
yeah yes sir when you were planning the
book did you ever think of maybe going
fiction and write a novel or was all
this just to unbelievable to go Asian I
think this is a case where the the old
saying applies truth is stranger than
fiction
yes yeah that's a real good question
Johnny Martorano was was a very gifted
athlete he he was an all-state football
player he he could have gone to